welcome back to the toast and happy th
Thursday I hope you're doing well I miss
you all so much how you D my girl is Jax
is back she is back she was really sick
but she is back now she's still sick but
she feels better enough to podcast and
that is good enough for me hey ja how
you doing perfect intro sums it up I was
sick yesterday I'm still sick but
feeling better well enough to podcast so
you'll still get that nasally I have
entered my sticky shoeses era and I'm
not going to lie I've been practicing
songs that I was going to sing and this
is the song I decided to sing CU I was
like I didn't want to do the climb again
because you guys know I've mastered it
yeah it's like boring at this point
right it's like try a classic challenge
yourself
right goodbye goodbye goodbye you were
bigger than the whole
sky you are more than just a short I
can't hear myself with my headphones
hold on I feel like you're you're like a
real singer like taking your earpiece
out I've got a lot to Pine about I've
got a lot to live without I'm never
going to meet what could have been would
have been what should have been
[Music]
you yeah so that's just a little treat
for you guys today yeah so that's that
on that so that's said on that and we
have multiple treats today one the show
itself always a treat treats Galore two
we're showing you some new winter merch
you guys Claude and I have been working
on a little winter collection for you
using our favorite word that we have yet
to
capitalize I was going to say something
like design no like when you put it in
like create okay I'm not going to get
the word because um I'm sick and I'm in
a fog but we have have this gorgeous
wench holiday merch I am wearing the
cream wench reindeer set I'm going to
move my microphone so you can see and
the matching sweatpants I'm in a size XL
I could have done a large yeah I'm
feeling small yeah I'm in a size medium
I could not have done a small I could
not uh the quality is so cozy and so
cute there's a little the toast
established 2018 on the sleeve this is
all going to drop on Monday so we wanted
to give you ample time to know what's
coming Claudia's in are black W she
lights set toasty lights we don't know
her W she lights we know her except it
says wench not W she just want to make
that clear wench on the breasts and
wench on the thigh double the Wench
double the fun also there's a wench on
the thigh for me as well yeah holiday
collection 2023 greater than everything
we've ever done in our lives it's so
cozy I'm loving my FIT today so that
also just makes it a great episode The
merch is going to drop Monday at 10:00
a.m. eastern time don't worry we will
keep reiterating that to you throughout
the next 5 days you can get it at shop
toast
merch.com not to be confused again with
shop Chanel shop air maze but shop toast
merch shop toast merch we are dropping
our holiday merch a little bit early for
a multipe of reasons one that holiday
shipping ain't a joke we want to get it
out to everyone we're also doing
pre-orders so that everybody can get the
size that they want so the collection
will be up for probably 2 days give
everyone a chance to get exactly what
they want and then we will close it and
start shipping out and make the
sweatshirts so we just wanted to make
sure a everybody gets what they want and
B we have enough time to ship out all
the orders so that it gets to you before
the holidays keep that in mind we're
very excited about this colle will'll be
teasing you know getting some good
product shots some Jackie and I are kind
of like modeling it'll all be on our
Instagram throughout the rest of the
week and the weekend so make sure you're
following the toast Instagram I feel
like that needs to be said I feel like
we haven't modeled in a
while let me think the last time I
modeled when was the last time I was on
set I don't know I'm just like
constantly like like always on sets I
can't even keep track of my I kind of
took a Hiatus for modeling oh let's talk
about that is because the industry is so
toxic the industry is toxic I needed to
kind of step away and Center myself of
course um and come back to it with more
of a level head so now I feel ready to
re-enter the sphere of modeling I'm so
glad yeah it was what was best for me
that's good it is good so toast merch
very exciting we couldn't wait another
minute we got our samples and we were
like
let's go I have to wear this there's
nothing else I want to wear today is the
problem we got our samples and we
said let's go girls let's go girly
swirlies yeah so um you did the toast
with Ben yesterday I did and he wanted
me to come on here and apologize for not
choosing him as my host should something
happen he was shook that like when I
recapped that conversation for him when
when we were talking on Tuesday like if
you were to if I were to quit who would
you choose and if I were to you know
what I mean and I told Ben and I was
trying to I thought it was like a
compliment when I was saying it I was
like I chose you and Jackie chose like
obviously olir or Mar and then he he was
so offended and I was like it didn't
even occur to me that Ben would be
offended by that I would think if
anything my husband would be offending
cuz you chose your your rose was your
husband and then I chose my sisters like
I never even thought Ben but then he
said to me he was like well I thought
you would have just chose me cuz I'm a
good podcaster and I said well that's
why I chose him
and I said that's a good
point that was a good point so he's
definitely in the mix he's definitely
top three but that's so B to like I
shared with him a nice story and he only
sees that you didn't choose him not that
I chose him I just feel like if I had
said Ben also that would have been crazy
no not only that like we'd make a
monster out of him we we have to keep
him grounded and it's like you can no
longer do the toast and it wasn't like
if something happened to one of us it
was like if you decided not to do it
anymore so like that would obviously
connote
something a little negative something a
little negative even if it was just like
the toast was bad for your mental health
or something like right so you're going
to put your husband in the arena I just
feel like that would have been a crazier
response no I think more so is like we
couldn't have both said Ben for the sake
of Ben's big head no but like that just
I think that would have been really
weird if I said Ben honestly I
understand like where he's coming from
he's top tier podcaster up for the job
and like the Ben and Jackie episodes
they are great they're great yeah the
sponge and swane effect we have a great
Rapport we really do like he would make
a great host and I would definitely put
him up for some screen testing I just
think if I answered with Ben also that
would have been really weird now I'm
kind of rethinking my answer
because like I love love love love love
doing the show with you but if I had to
say like one negative thing it's like
it's about both of us you know if I had
my DS it would all be about me so if I
had the if you quit like and I could
have the opportunity for it to be all
about me I might have like a rotating
like just so that it's always about me
and then the co-host is just kind of
fluid oh no I don't think that's stable
enough but if you do want it to be all
about you you could have like a little
producer off to the side with a
microphone who you're like talking to
but like the O who only speaks when
spoken to I by the way I can't think of
a job I'd be less qualified for than
like that role of like the on air
producer who only speaks when spoken to
that is my worst nightmare I'd just be
like turning bright red my veins would
be popping out like trying not to say
stuff yes would you rather be the
producer who only spoke speaks when
spoken to or set up chairs on the
beach the producer because he's probably
sitting yeah but you're so athletic now
you would get a tan you probably are
rethinking that but no I'm not and by
the way you know Jimmy Fallon has one of
those speakers I feel like he's not on
the show anymore but like that little
guy you know Steve no Steve okay gmo's
Jimmy
Kimmel Jimmy Fallon has that guy Steve
with the glasses who stands off to the
side um first of all he hasn't been seen
in a while like is he still on the show
and two Jimmy Kimmel makes his off air
producer who sometimes says stuff he
makes him stand he's standing the whole
time that I wouldn't do that job that
ain't right
Jimmy bigger
one in size or in show physically bigger
taller or wider cuz Jimmy Kimel I think
struggles with his weight but Jimmy
Fallon is taller oh shoot okay uh not
the one from the movie with Drew
Barrymore okay
is hosting the Oscars not a story but
just a note it's so not worthy of a
story like I literally saw that and I I
like I tried to care less but I couldn't
no I know and it's not like there was an
abundance of stories today like I could
have chosen it right right so we could
have had you know the same conversation
about hosts and you know give it to
theovon or Tim Dylan but I wasn't in the
mood speaking of story selections did
you choose the story about Travis Kel's
old tweets no I didn't but can we talk
about it really briefly yeah of course
now it's a hilarious story but it's
worth noting that people went to
Travis's Twitter find Tweets in bad
faith like it was not Faith they were
bad faith actors bfas they were bfas and
what ended up happening was funny but
like we need to stop doing that we just
absolutely need to no I'm glad that
you're mentioning that and I'm
out for Travis the result was hilarious
the tweets that they found from when he
was super young are so mind-numbingly
stupid and moronic like he's literally
tweeting like can't wait to get Chipotle
nap time I just saw a squirrel in the
park like an actual 14-year-old it's so
precious it's so sweet and I think it
really is like an indicator of like he's
always just been like this big goofball
but let's not forget like people went
there with bad intentions yeah they did
stop it stop it like they're tailor fans
but they clearly don't want her to be
happy cuz what if they had found what
they were looking for well you know they
found what they were looking for with
Britney Mahomes of course they like
searched through her old tweets the
words Taylor Swift and there was like
three tweets they weren't terrible it
was just like I wonder if Taylor Swift
will ever write about anything other
than her relationships and then there
was another one that was like Taylor
Swift winning every award she was
obviously like live tweeting some award
show at the time Taylor Swift live uh
winning every award less than less than
less than less than less than at this
point I'm matter at the people who go
and find those types of things and the
people like
I don't care that Britney Mahomes 10
years ago was you know frustrated Taylor
Swift won Embry award like it's so wrong
yeah but I do wonder how Taylor feels
about it it's so awkward it's so awkward
it's so awkward and the thing is
sometimes you meet someone or you know
someone and you don't like them at first
and then years later you end up like
being really good friends with them and
it's like oh haaha and you as a human
being like it's a that privilege of what
you first thought of them is like it's
it's your it's private yeah now the
internet has kind of stripped that away
it's weird when it's like you're a fan
of someone's and you're commenting on
them and then you know them yeah it's
just weird and unnecessary like why' you
have to go there we all feel weird about
it yeah like let's just not like when I
saw that like I felt really awkward yeah
what if we just didn't yeah that's what
I'm saying let's not and say we did
let's not even say we did I a few months
ago was thinking about a time in my life
where my rebuttal to absolutely anything
that was said to me was let's not and
say we did and that was a yeah no like
it was a sleigh and I need to start
bringing it back no please don't it's
literally so rude and
condescending that's like when
everyone's rebuttal was you would oh
that's [__] rude I thought you were
going to say when everybody's rebuttal
was like your mom right right right of
course that just lacked creativity
that's not even a good one but like you
would was so nasty by the
way you would that was dark
dark when you were talking when you were
talking [__] about someone you were like
oh she would yeah actually I still say
that no it's so mean yeah I will I will
and I can and I shall oh speaking
of
words I have made significant progress
in the book The Fourth Wing I'm so glad
I stuck with it I'm 85% there I'll
probably finish it
today oh honestly everybody was like the
beginning yeah yeah yeah and I kept
going and I was like 20 25 30 35 and I'm
like this book is not getting better and
seriously like it's literally one one
word that changes it like 35% you're
you're there like I had I've never had
such like an instant shift usually it's
more more gradual I'm getting more into
it and then I love it literally in one
second loved yeah also I meant to tell
you I know you said Ana Taylor Joy
should play Violet I disagree um but
when we did redheads when I would think
of like Zaden and violet you know who I
think of who Jacob a Lordi and Olivia
Jade like he's so tall she's so small no
I love it I love it they should be the
Le let's talk about this really quickly
so the book has been optioned for a
series at Amazon so we know it's being
brought to a screen near us I do I did
see it more as like a movie franchise
there's so many things in the book that
remind me so much of Hunger Games I
think it's going to be a movie I heard
series okay okay and even if it's on
Amazon like this needs to be something
in the theaters like this is going to
bring back like those big franchises
there's many Twilight references there's
so honestly I see it so much as like a
Hunger Games type of thing me too like
Peta and Gale duh yeah duh um but of
course casting comes to mind and I I do
really see Violet as Anya Taylor Joy
except like violet physically is so
small and short short and Anya Taylor
Joy is just too tall for it but I'm
sorry the hair the face the body like
it's giving Violet soring Gale I stand
by that I understand um and I also but I
do think she's also 18 like we need
someone really young right I think it
would probably be an
unknown kind of like or you know an up
and cominging actress kind of like how
Jennifer Lawrence was Chris and Stewart
like they had worked before but they
weren't household names I love that yeah
and for
Zaden I don't picture Zaden when I'm
reading it so much as I picture Violet
like I don't really know what Zaden
looks like I can't I can't put my finger
on it I think on redheads we do the
Hollywood treatment if you've read
fourth wi go listen to the redheads
episode we all gave our casting
suggestions I like Jacobi someone said
Charles
Melton you know he's from Riverdale I
like that I like that because I like
he's very handsome and I also feel like
the only real descriptors they gave is
that he has very like tan bronzed skin
and brown hair yeah so it could be
anyone really Jacob AI with a spray tan
yeah but somebody big
tall yeah and like chiseled yeah
chiseled and who's like he's 23 and
she's 20 20 yeah CU I just started um
the second book and she just turned 21
and my book club has hit a kind of fork
in the road for this month because we're
reading Matthew Perry's Memoir and
there's like two or three girlies in the
book club who are so against Kindles
like we talk about it every week like
they they just read hard cover books and
the book is like sold out everywhere oh
so like they went to go purchase and
there was there are no books well maybe
a toaster is selling a copy oh if you're
selling a copy LMK there's always people
selling copies of books in the redhead's
Facebook group where amazing things
happen I will Source yeah that's a good
call it is a good call you're welcome so
I'm loving the book I'm going to read
the sequel of course and everyone was
right I'm so glad I was reading the
sequel last night I felt like I was
reading so much and I was at 4% so
that's tough no but like it must be in a
thousand page book let me I I meant to
look up how many pages it is oh don't
ruin it for me cuz you know that I won't
want to no but like if you love it then
it's just more yeah yeah okay it is no
623 same as fourth wi oh fourth wi is
600 Pages pretty sure wow if I had known
that before I wouldn't have read it
that's why we keep things from you it's
true it's so important 528 528 okay okay
yeah it's important um so I'm looking
forward to like keeping up with the
casting of that series or movie or
whatever it's going to end up being
that'll be fabulous yeah very very
exciting and I'm so glad you're on board
and then you have to listen to the
redheads episode yeah of course I love
listening to the redheads episodes after
um I finish a book so I listen to The
Measure oh what you think who' you agree
with most um like kind of none of you
maybe Rebecca because you guys talked a
lot about how you thought the book was
very Coy and like I honestly didn't get
that at all yeah so Rebecca was like oh
my god I didn't even think of that and I
was like same okay that makes sense yeah
but it's such a great way and also like
sometimes when I read books that's why I
need to listen to the fourth wi um
redheads episode like you miss like I
said like I said earlier in the book
like I'm I'm earlier in the week I'm
really not like the smartest person
especially book smart so I feel like
stuff really goes over my head like
details or you know meaning we all had
that experience with fourth wi where
it's like someone noticed something that
the others didn't and we were all like
learning more because there's a lot of
stuff in the book yeah speaking of um KY
I'm pretty sure I have
Co yikes stay away Throwback Thursday
by the way I feel like now like it's
November yeah and like before Co let's
remember like during this time of year
like people would get the flu they would
get the cold like it's just like being
sick in the winter no I'm literally just
sick I assumed I had a cold but then my
friend has covid and she was telling me
her symptoms and I was like yeah those
are my symptoms too and then yesterday I
couldn't taste or smell and that has
never happened to me before that's by
the way that's happened to me though no
Claudia like I'm not but with the cold
like yeah you lose you can't
yeah no I've never like been eating
something and I couldn't like I was
eating um everything bagel crisps that's
a flavorful snack couldn't taste a thing
it could have been anything okay but by
the way like that has happened to me
many times when I'm sick I don't feel
like that's a CO exclusive thing it when
your nose gets so blocked up it's math I
mean it's science no I know but I've
never had the experience of not being
able to taste period it's coming back
today which is which is good because
it's weird to not be able to taste it's
like oh I should take advant of this eat
healthy yeah by the way when I the last
time I think I was at your house and I
was so sick I literally ate broccoli
because I couldn't taste I'm like might
as well I know but it's also I'm
realizing like so psychological it's
like well I want to curl up with a bag
of pretzels yeah not a bag of broccoli
not a bag of broccoli even though I did
the other day steam some broccoli and
eat it that's disgusting no because last
week I was making broccoli egg bites and
I had leftover broccoli that was like
seasoned so I just started eating it I
was like this is so good I should make
this for a snack let's not and say we
did anyways refu lay met to
me reflu lay met you do you need to blow
your nose off camera you sound yes I'm
waiting for the ad break I'm going to go
hard no go cuz I have something else to
say and you can it'll give you like 10
seconds okay I'm going to take my
headphones off so that I can might go
live your best life okay but I'm going
to miss what you're going to say very
sad oh okay just give me a teaser no so
I went last night to a dinner to
celebrate the opening of the new Katon
Barrel store in flat iron and oh my my
God like I've never been like a Crate
and Barrel girly like I I go more CB2
cuz like it's cheaper and it's a 25,000
Foot Store it looks seriously like a
Costco like it's huge it was so sick it
was so gorina there was like a dinner
downstairs for like 50 people but
upstairs you could just like walk around
the store take pictures oh my God I'm so
in the holiday spirit now they had like
Christmas trees like an ornament making
thing and they like it was so sick and I
just wanted to say like it opened today
like I'm going to be spending my time at
Crate and Barrel like I've never been
one of those girls with my new house
yeah you need to make selections okay go
go go yeah I'm going to mute I'm
actually going to get up and mute my
microphone without further ad from this
nasly wench here are the fast five
stories that you need to
know and the fast five stories that you
need to know are brought to you by
Mattress Firm when you sleep on the
right mattress everything becomes clear
Mattress Firm carries a wide selection
of high quality mattresses from top
brands at every price price point excuse
me and the mattress matters mattress
firms firm will find yours this Black
Friday sale take advantage I feel like a
mattress is an investment a mattress is
the one thing in your life that I think
is most important honestly I would say
that and with mattress firm's Black
Friday sale it's a great time to take
advantage my mattress is from Mattress
Firm I bought it at one of their big
annual sales and with Black Friday
coming up do not miss out you can score
major deals on top brands for Mattress
firms at Black Friday sale if you're a
parent you know like sleep can decline
as you get older with the kids and the
problems and everything there's never
bad time in your life to invest in a
good decent mattress sleep plays a key
role in our emotional well-being
especially during Parenthood it's
important to support good sleep Habits
by optimizing you and your family's
routine around sleep and bedtime as
sleep disruptors change whether due to
age location or the arrival of new
children a foundation/ routine will help
you overcome those
hurdles
so with the holidays coming up give
yourself the gift of good rest this year
you know that um Mattress Firm carries
some of the finest Brands mine is temper
Pedic they have you know Sterns and
Foster they have all the greatest brands
in my opinion so make sure to take
advantage of the Black Friday sale at
Mattress Firm take 120 nights to make
sure it's right for you or your money
back you can shop in store online at
mattressfirm.com today's episode is also
brought to you by game time you
shouldn't have to worry when you buy
tickets to your next big event game time
is the fast and easy way to buy tickets
for all the sports music comedy and
Theater events near you with killer last
minute deals all in prices views from
your seat and their best price guante
game time takes the guesswork out of
buying tickets game time is the only
ticketing app that gives you complete
peace of mind with your purchase see the
view from your seat before you buy so
you know exactly what to expect when you
arrive all in prices shows your total
upfront so you know what you're getting
that you're getting a great deal before
you check out and you can buy ticket
tickets in seconds with two Taps game
time has deals on tickets right up to
the start of the event and even an hour
after it starts so it's really the place
to find last minute seats find exclusive
Flash Deals and sponsored deals on
tickets for football basketball baseball
concerts comedy theater and more and
with Zone deals you can pick the section
and game time will pick the seats for
you for Big Time Savings and the game
time guad and team means that you'll
always get the best price if you find
tickets in the same section in row for
Less game time will credit you 110% of
the difference so take the guest workk
out of buying tickets with Game Time
download the game time app create an
account and use code toast for $20 off
your first purchase game time is just a
great app to constantly have on your
phone whether you travel for work or you
know you live in a fabulous City like I
do nevi York and there's always stuff
going on have the game time app it's a
great way to discover things going on in
your city terms apply when you download
the the game time app create an account
and use code toast for $20 off your
first purchase again create that account
redeem code t o a s for $20 off download
game time today last minute tickets
lowest price guante today's episode is
also brought to you by Quint I love
high-end luxury goods as much as an
excal but sometimes our wallets aren't
on the same page and that was until we
found Quint our go-to place for luxury
Essentials at prices Within Reach so
quin's business model just makes sense
they create Timely Classics that never
go out of style you can have them in
your closet forever like they have 100%
Mongolian cashmere sweaters from $50
washable silk tops and dresses
flattering pants but the best price is
that quint's items are priced 50 to 80%
less than similar Brands because they
partner directly with top factories they
cut the cost of the middleman and pass
the savings on to the customer they only
work with factories that use safe
ethical and responsible manufacturing
practices practices and premium fabrics
and finishes I have so many great pieces
from Quinns every time I wear this like
beige Kashmir v-neck sweater I get so
many questions about it it's so wellmade
it's cashmere and it was very reasonably
priced and it's now my second winter
with it it really is very um wellmade I
have a great pair of slacks you know you
need slacks a nice like tailored black
pant you
do so you can get affordable luxury with
Quin go to quinn.com toast for free
shipping on your order and 365 day
returns these are pieces that will last
you a long time they are really wellmade
they are fairly priced and so if you're
looking to build like a great capsule
wardrobe of like staple pieces that are
wellmade head to qu
nc.com toast to get free shipping and
free 365 day returns that's quinn.com
toast thank you lot I feel like a new
woman well oh I'm so good I'm so glad do
I sound like one yes you sound great and
clear crystal clear crystal I wonder how
long I'll have hopefully till the next
ad break till I need to expel myself
again you let me know I will will we can
always cut just let me it's sound a big
deal oh that's true that's true I like
you know sneaking it in yeah I know our
next our first story not our next one
fire Festival 2 kicks off with zero
gravity flights and no
catastrophes if convicted frauder Billy
McFarland the guy behind the catastroph
catastrophically incompetent fire
Festival took you to a remote air strip
outside of New York City and told you to
get on a tiny plane to experience zero
gravity flight would you climb aboard
apparently some people would page six
hears that excon Billy McFarland took a
group of around 75 of the first people
to buy tickets for his doover event fire
Festival 2 to an Airfield in Orange
County New York and sent them up in
private planes to experience
weightlessness Pilots can create the
feeling of weightlessness even inside
the Earth's atmosphere yeah they did it
on The Bachelor by flying through a
certain kind of Arc is that what Vanessa
did Vanessa gral did when she threw up
yeah literally I have so many many
things to say um so he's doing a fire
Festival too people have bought tickets
the first purchasers got to experience
weightlessness with Billy McFarland the
fact that there are 75 people who
purchase tickets like they are [__]
morons like I I'm sorry like I don't
know what's going to go wrong but I will
I will not feel bad for them like I
won't like this is so stupid second of
all fire festival and Billy McFarland is
a pop culture moment I am so done with
like I don't want to hear him on podcast
I don't want to see him doing interviews
I don't want to hear about what his next
plans are for like I don't care can we
stop like we get so obsessed with these
things and we ruin them like okay I
understand when the documentaries came
out like sure it was fun that was years
ago why are we still talking about this
person I mean because it was such a
moment I think everyone's trying to
recreate the moment it's giving Su it's
giving you know shipping container like
trying to squeeze through trying to make
a Suz moment the way I feel about Billy
though I feel differently I'm just like
bro like if at first you don't succeed
try try try again I love this for him I
think he should keep going I hope fire
Festival to is a massive success and he
proves all the haters wrong I hope that
for
him I don't care like that's the thing
succeed or not like my life remains
unaffected I will never purchase like I
cannot and by the way not only did they
buy a ticket they also bought a ticket
with like more dangerous activities like
I would never go on a plane that was
procured by Billy McFarland yeah but if
you watch the documentaries about fire
Festival like Billy just has this I'm
sorry to say entrepreneurial spirit that
you cannot quell even when hey when he
was doing it's an entrepreneurial Spirit
coupled with a fraudster spirit that
makes for this beautiful Enigma that is
Billy McFarland even when he was doing
those credit cards like he just wants to
build something no he just want money
his name should be Bild Bild D McFarland
yeah yeah so you know you can't crush
his Spirit he paid the time for the
crime he did he did but I'm just so
uninterested in the comings and goings
of fire Festival 1.0 2.0 3.04 like I
don't care and I think also the people
who buy tickets they just want to be a
part of something I think it speaks to
like a deep by a deep like loneliness
and deep desire to be in a documentary
you know by the way nobody on the planet
understands that better than me I every
day I wake up and I say what can I be a
part of today but not at the expense of
my own life yeah but did they diee but
did they die did you die though but did
you die no they didn't this
time yeah he has the same energy as that
guy who created the submersible
company yes like trying to do something
that can't be done for a
reason for a reason there's a reason why
you can't do a music festival on a
remote island because they don't have
the infrastructure right right there's a
reason why it hasn't been done before
like I'm just like if I never heard the
words fire Festival again like I would
be fine you know I'm at that place now
I'm at the place where it's like history
to me and I I can relive it like at a
glance I'm not in it like now it's like
it's far enough away that I can
re-engage from time to time for me It
Isn't Love is it it isn't hate it's just
indifference okay it sounds a little
like hate no actually I feel very
calm it's indifference okay it's
indifference sorry I I am
indifferent like I feel similarly people
are always grouping them together like
he and anad Deli I he she did come to
mine as a fraudster with an
entrepreneurial pral Spirit who like the
media won't let you forget yeah I guess
my treatment of of these two is a little
different and is it cuz Anna's a woman
is it internalized
misogyny no I think it's because what
anad delie was doing was just kind of
like specific to her and I don't even
know what she was doing whereas like she
was stealing money from Banks it's hard
to be sad for no it's not even like I
feel sad but like Billy McFarland it was
like the influencers the celebrities
like everybody was involved in what he
it was just so much bigger than him
whereas I feel like what anad Delby was
doing like was only you know a little
circle jerk yeah it wasn't big enough
for me to care about no there like there
were actual victims in the fire Festival
Saga there were people there there are
all these different if anything you
should dislike Billy McFarland more than
you dislike anad
Delby but we're talking about bamian no
I know but we're not talking about a
dislike for the scam they did we're
talking about a dislike for the media
cover like the the Press about them and
them as like public figures how about
this I don't like either of them yeah I
wouldn't say I like either of them and
in terms of the content that was made
from their scandals like I quite enjoyed
inventing Anna I quite enjoyed the fire
festivals I never saw them maybe that's
why maybe cuz it was like really crazy
I'm sure it was really crazy it was just
one of those Trends I just like didn't
participate in that's like me and Tiger
King H what a blessing that was yeah to
not participate or to not participate
show
itself no to not participate for some
people like it was the biggest blessing
in their life and that's what's wrong
with this country there's a lot of
things wrong with this country can you
tell me about this Osama Bin Laden Tik
Tok thing I would love to pleas like I I
think I know what's happening and I
can't believe it I need you to break it
down for me apparently like while AMA
was kicking you know in that Palace of
his he had penned this open letter a
scholar if you will to the United States
with his just you know his philosophies
and his thoughts you know on the matter
and it was like I don't think it was you
know made such made waves when it was
published but somebody on Tik Tok posted
about it and it's gone viral and people
are like you know posting videos
recapping and sharing their thoughts on
the uh letter to America penned by Osama
Bin Laden and I will say it's important
to know most of the people who made
videos were
women just thought that was an important
thing to add
um being like you know Osama had a point
Osama had a point being like let's talk
about this letter and I'd be like yeah
let's talk about it and if I watch a
video horrified that the the thoughts
they were having on the letter weren't
the same as my thoughts and I honestly
think people like this really need to be
watched by the FBI like it's insane it's
insane what's osama's
thesis the thing is I don't know is it
you know America needs to be destroyed
yeah it's like you know the free
freedoms and that you know our
government is lying to us like it's
insane it's written by Osama bin ladin
no it's literally Osama no but it's not
figuratively Osama it's not giving Osama
no no in a literal sense in a physical
sense in a tangible sense it's Osama Bin
Laden yeah but those people on Tik Tok
and who are empath these empaths for
Osama they weren't alive during 911 most
of them like and it shows that's what um
that's what the but you really shouldn't
have to be alive for something to
understand not even empathy like Common
Sense wait that just reminded me of
something the craziest thing happened to
me last night like this is Major te I
have to share oh so I told you this did
you not read my text in the chat you did
oh oh yeah yeah yeah sorry okay crazy
like more than one crazy thing can
happen what do people like to say two
crazy things can be true at the same
time time no they just say two things
can be true at but I'm make I'm you're
making it your own I'm meeting the
moment so I feel like I'm not supposed
to share this but like I don't care yeah
was it not like a private thing oh it
was should I not I don't know that's why
I I assumed it was a private thing like
it was no it was it was but like would
this person
care I don't know
him
[__] [__] maybe you're right maybe
you're right
I'm really sorry that was not cool guys
like
okay maybe like one day maybe tomorrow
if you if you find out more information
I'm sure someone will actually write it
up I'm sure there was like a mole I
thought there would definitely be a mole
and that this thing would be on page six
not page and could say it was there it's
not really a page six type thing yes it
is yes it is I would say okay let's stop
talking about a thing I can't share
because that's so annoying and I'm
really sorry but you're right I want get
in trouble T's gonna work to find out if
she can share let me just ask someone
what they think okay yeah and then we
could Circle back to it in the meantime
I'll tell you our Second
Story now usually haircuts do not make
news on this show and I think that's a
policy we should stick by but Harry
Styles has given fans a closer look at
his shaved head and he's dividing his
fans wait I'm sorry some notes from
Osama Bin Laden's letter because I just
opened this text message and it says so
he says that he really really feels that
people should abscond from
homosexuality Jews run
everything and that was pretty much the
thesis and so the
women and the women loved it and that's
why I've said it once and I'll say again
I'm not a woman who brought blindly
supports other women because I've seen
some of those women's Tik toks and they
don't have my support I I mean maybe
they didn't get to the part about like
how Osama feels about
women yeah I mean he loved women maybe
they did he married all different types
of women at all different ages yeah and
all at the same
time uh that is the craziest
thing it's literally Osama okay Harry
Styles shaped his head we talked about
it earlier this week but like he posted
a picture fans are divided I'm making an
exception to the rule we're talking
about a haircut because this is big news
you know he's they're calling him
hairless
Styles I don't love it I don't love it
and I knew that it was coming I saw a
very blurry picture of like his
silhouette so I had a feeling I would
what it was would look like and it
doesn't look like what I thought it was
and it looks bad so do you not feel like
he's a David
beckup no so I would have thought he was
one of these people who could pull off
any hairstyle and like I really don't
like it I don't dislike it he's a NIC
looking man but it definitely takes away
and he looks a lot older takes away some
of that boyish charm which I think he
likes but he looks like a lot of other
people now and I feel like
before he was you know one of a kind
yeah but now he looks like a number like
just like an artist yeah that's true
actually that's a great point I just
think aesthetically it's not my favorite
you prefer hairful styles hairful
styles hairy styles hairy styles yeah me
too though I I do like change you know
whenever someone cuts their hair even if
it like it's not your best cut like I
appreciate that you tried something
new yeah yeah and Harry's always had
like a multitude of hair we remember the
shoulder length he's grown out his hair
he's cut his hair this most recent one
with very like Bachelor esque you know
fluffy I liked that one for the Love on
tour um this just isn't my favorite but
he you're right he definitely fancies
himself a David Beckham type yeah and he
is good-looking enough that it really
doesn't matter
but it's different it hits
different it hits different this time
catastrophic L moving on was always easy
for me to do speaking of Taylor Swift
songs I watched the show the Buccaneers
on Apple TV I think it's like four or
five episodes and when I started it I
was regretting it because it's not good
but I kept watching I kept watching
because like I already gotten into it
and I don't want to take the time to get
into another show I'm not going to like
it's just like so historically
inaccurate like it's said in like 1870
and it's like but it's meant to be it's
like the way that they're behaving these
girls like they would never like no one
would ever and it's about like you know
American Rich American like guilded age
girls like going over to Britain and you
know the broke Lords want to marry them
whatever and the way that these American
girls are behaving like I know there was
a difference between like the Americans
and the British but this is on it's
ridiculous they're like constantly
running around first of all in the
opening scene they're like showing their
arms like I don't think anyone was
showing like it but it it's like they
wanted to do a modern show about like
love and whatever just set in a
different time and it's just B bothering
me how there's like it's so devoid from
like historical accuracy just in terms
of like I like those like small cultural
things even in one scene she's giving
the baby a bottle which I'm obsessed
with like how people like breast nurse
rear children before there were breast
pumps formula everything and the bottle
is like this little Glass boat and I
thought that was so interesting and like
that's why I like shows like this you
like learn things like that I want more
of that not sleeveless women running
around in corsets like no they would
never be allowed out of the house like
that wait you also just reminded me like
nobody's talking about the fact that
Gilded Age is back because it's one
episode at a time and the show's not
good enough for me to watch it it's not
Game of Thrones sorry no but I do feel
like it could be one of those shows that
like by the time we hit like season
three or four like it's so popular and
it gets like really good cuz it's there
the makings of it are there it's
beautifully done yeah I mean I like it
because it's my but it's not the best of
the best no it's not like it's Julian
fellows but it's not downt no no no no
no and it does give like Community
there's something about it that's like
Community Theater I'm sorry it's first
of all there's a lot of things about it
but like Cynthia Nixon playing something
other than Miranda Hobbs is literally
it's just impossible it's impossible to
suspend your disbelief and believe that
you know she's a woman living in the
guilded age and just the accents like
it's
comical yeah and even those new nvo
Reach people across the
street like it's just
so put on like you feel like you're
watching a fake show yeah yeah you don't
feel transported you don't so Buccaneers
but now that I've gotten a few episodes
like I'm into the storyline it's good
Christina Hendrick in is in it and she's
amazing uh I love that [__] she's so
different in the show she plays the
mother but she is just really acting
through she's really acting well like
the fact that we live in a world where
Bryce Dallas Howard and Christina
Hendricks both exist and they're not the
same person like I'll never understand
that yeah but sometimes one of them is
working and so the other one shows up
like it's nice to have like a backup
redhe head yeah there's two there we get
two I I don't think I could possibly
tell them apart except because I watched
Madmen like I definitely
recognize Christina Hendrick as a
redhead I can tell them apart with ease
like same with like Amy Adams and Isa
Fisher I'm sorry those two women don't
look alike everyone thinks they're the
same person no I could tell I'm a part
of flash but those are the four redheads
and then Jessica Chastain rounded out
and we have a basketball
team the uh the fire
crotches sorry that's disgusting it is
it's like a disgusting word I can't
believe I just Ed that I'm disgusting
you are I am are you ready ready for our
next story I just feel you know when you
can feel energy in a room okay I feel
like there's like a mouse in here like I
can just feel it maybe it's you like
we've been in this studio for many many
years we've never seen a mouse I just
think my time is up you know maybe
you're the
mouse but I'm not cuz I'm a girl there
could be girl mouses I'm a human girl is
the mouse in the room with us I believe
it
is piece of
cheese you think I have cheese oh yeah I
think there's a cheese shink in the
fridge
honestly maybe that's why we have a
mouse and if it's not there the mouse
already got it
yeah any other thoughts before I can add
into the next story no I've been told I
really shouldn't share my tea and I'm
really sorry to have brought it up thank
you for the apology I'm glad I caught
you in time yeah are next story is a a
story that I'm very passionate
about wow what story number is this
three okay Bachelorette star Blake hzman
is expecting his first baby with Love is
Blind Alum gianina jbell so for people
who watch love is blind or the bachelor
Bachelorette you probably know that
Blake hzman from Becca season of The
Bachelor is dating gianina from Love is
Blind who was engaged to Daman and she
lost her butterflies they have been she
lost her butterflies they've been
together
for a while like over a year maybe two
years they met on like a reality show
where like cast offs of other reality
shows go I don't know which one
specifically maybe very like MTV X on
the be like sex on the beach sort of
thing um but not that one yeah and
they've been going steady for a really
long time and now they are pregnant and
I am just over the moon for them no I
will say like this is the ending nobody
saw coming you know it's very sweet I
just yes like I think their Instagram
content is insane Jackie's always
sending it to me like I find it very
triggering um but that's neither here
nor there cuz I actually think this is
lovely and I'm really happy for them I'm
really happy for them you couldn't write
a better ending to both of these to both
of these shows even like the fact that I
think a lot of people you know they go
on shows like famous and love you know
crossover shows they meet someone
probably have a lot in common with them
because you've both been on a reality
show but it never lasts and these two
are defying the odds
yeah I agree it's really nice the
pregnancy announcement was really
beautiful and like it's the proof is in
the pudding it's true it's true and I
also feel like they're even though like
I was saying like they're so like their
Instagram is just insane like photo
shoots it's a lot I also weirdly feel
like they're very lowkey I feel like a
lot of people don't even know that these
two are dating not enough people know is
how I feel and it's my job to share it
with the world and to publicize the nice
you have to having a baby together yeah
and like I feel I I feel as though like
no nobody really knows like either of
these people on a real personal level
cuz they both kind of had like these
insane personalities on their shows and
they both had crazy
arcs right but I feel like they know
each other right they see each other
they've seen each other at their best
and at their worst and they're choosing
to forge ahead so I believe their love
find you a love like Blake and gianina
no it's really nice I'm I'm happy for
this show
I always forget about his Bachelor in
Paradise Den like I always just think of
him as like Becca's runner
up I don't think of him
like ever but if I had to think of him I
think of him as like Jason taric right
yeah but now I'm remembering kin Stage
Coach text messages text messages Hannah
G what did Hannah G do he just like
really wanted to date her in Paradise
even though he had already had a thing
with kin but he asked tasa out on a date
even though Hanah was there he was just
a mess messy messy hzman yeah Hanah G
made the right call she look at her I
mean everybody made the right calls for
themselves look at Blake yeah there was
an that was an like a good ERA of
Bachelor in Paradise and we did get a
lot of couples from that time Kayla de
yeah obsessed obsessed Hannah and Dylan
yeah they just got married yeah who else
was who else anyone tasa but she didn't
endend up with anyone from that Jean
Paul Jones that was like a crazy time
yeah
jpj so maslov to Blake and gianina
mazeltov wishing you well wishing you so
well so thankful to have a reason to
discuss them before we dive into the
next story let me tell you that the next
story and the rest of the show are
brought to you by rakitin for toaster
who are longtime listeners you know that
we love rakitin one of the
quintessential hacks to save money while
shopping rakitin is is an app that gives
you cash back on the stores you are
already buying from which you can stack
on top of holiday deals to maximize your
savings then it lets you deposit your
cashback earnings directly into your
PayPal or it's sent to you via a check
back to you and the holiday season is
upon us which means it is the time to be
using the app they are having their
highest cash back rates of the Year from
Black Friday to Cyber Monday with Brands
giving up to 15% cash back on stores
that you are already shopping at so in
the spirit of the holidays and all this
money that rakitin is going to be saving
you let's play a little game of my
favorite game a little let's play around
of my favorite game this or that but
it's going to be holiday gift Edition
okay so we're going to be spending
hypothetical money you know that's our
absolute favorite thing to do here like
when we're going to win the lottery
literally so let's get into it these are
all things you can and will be saving
money and getting cash back on at rutin
so tell me what you would prefer okay a
brand new set of makeup from
tarte or new skin care a whole new
regime from
Kels ooh two brands that I love but here
I'm going to have to go necessity
because I have all tart makeup I have
the this is an unfair question cuz I was
going to say too like I'm on the tarte
pr list no I'm also on the K's PR list
is what I was going to say oh my God
yeah avocado cream they also make baby
products I use their baby lotion um so
are you going with
Kels I think I'm going to go with Keels
because out of necessity I technically I
have less kills than I have tar like I
have tarte makeup a lifetime supply yeah
I agree but if it was for you listener
dear
listener they're both great choices yeah
it just depends like are you a makeup
curer or you a skincare girlly what are
your needs this game this game is so
personal everything all right ready for
another one yeah would you prefer a
brand new away luggage o or a brand new
Dyson air wrap ooh ooh these are
hard I would choose the DIYs and air app
I have a DIYs and air wrap I know I'm we
have to talk hypothetically because I
have an away away suitcase and a dice
and air right but I just feel like you
can never have enough suitcases is how I
feel agreed but like a DIYs and air app
is like a once in A- lifetime sort of
also I use my DIYs and air app every day
my away suitcase like it would I would
only notice it a couple times a year and
I'd be like damn I wish I had an away
suitcase whereas every day I would need
my DIYs and air wrap Dyson airp is the
winner I like my Sketcher Sneakers but I
love but I love
okay this one's really hard would you
rather get five new Stanley water
bottles in any colors of your choice or
five pairs of Rayband sunglasses
whoa now I feel like the answer at first
would be Stanley I feel like the answer
at first would be Rayban because if you
do the monetary value that's technically
a bit of a higher value I don't know
these Stanley's these you know collab on
special edition I know but I'm so in my
Stanley era I'm by the way same my
Stanley's my life but like do I need
five yes one for every day a week with
sunglasses I really like change them up
all the time I'm kind of going Stanley I
think I'm going Rayban okay good we each
got what we wanted all right let's do
one more new ug slippers or Stuart
whitesman boots I guess it just depends
how big like of a slob you want to be
that day you know it just depends on the
day I I'm going Ugg slippers because I
literally just bought ug slippers
yesterday cuz I was like I'm going to
treat my food I'm going to my right now
myot like my slippers are so run down I
deserve a cozy pair of slippers this
season and so I would have gone like
slippers what about a whole new wardrobe
from Sachs or all new makeup from Ulta
Ulta carries everything like high low
but I'm going SX I'm going sax a whole
new wo from sax they literally have
everything like no they have like
underwear hos bralets like from top to
bottom yeah no I'll go with a makeup
free face yeah no I'll be so ugly but
dressed to the nines that nobody will
notice yeah so don't forget all of these
places that we just mentioned and so
many more get you cash back when you
shop with rakitin the good news is that
with rakitin you can have this and that
because this
game hypothetical it's hypothetical you
don't have to choose on Black Friday all
the way to Cyber Monday you can earn up
to 15% cash back on rutin from Brands
like Ugg Stanley Dyson Rayban Sachs Ulta
all the places we mentioned so I know it
sounds like there's got to be some sort
of gotcha moment from rakitin but
there's truly not membership is free
it's so easy to sign up and all you have
to do is download the rakitin app or
visit rakitin
docomomo app happy shopping stay safe
this holiday season ladies and gentlemen
thank you Claudia for that fun and
engaging game a pleasure I feel engaged
I'm glad M though I'm married oh plan on
words are you ready for our next story
yes it's some exciting news for the
children thank God Frozen 4 is in the
works at Disney Bob Iger reveals Disney
was there ever a three it's forthcoming
but before it even comes out they're
letting you know Frozen 4 is coming Bob
Iger revealed the studio is working on a
fourth Frozen movie in addition to the
previously announced Frozen 3 which
hasn't be been released yet he said
Frozen 3 is in the works and there might
be a frozen four in the works too he
said on GMA but I don't have much to say
about those films right now uh the
director who created the original movies
is hard at work on not one but two
actual stories of Frozen I wake up every
day mad that I wasn't Caston Frozen like
they didn't even know it at the time I'm
sure they thought it would be a great
payday like a big Disney movie they
didn't know the franchise they were
creating when they created that movie
and like I just think like how lucky
Adena Manzel Josh Gad Jonathan gra like
I'm so you CHR that's what I meant I'm
so jealous it's disgusting maybe there's
a new character that you could I would
love audition for I would love love love
that also speaking of Disney movies uh
Dwayne The Rock Johnson was on Jimmy
Fallon and he announced that there in
the works is a liveaction Moana that
he's going to obviously play Maui in
chef's kiss great idea this is what's
great about like having so much immedate
success with new movies like they could
also do this for Frozen right like Moana
is not problematic so in a few years
when they you know do it again they're
not going to have to you know remove the
dwarves right right no but I'm saying
like and I guess maybe it's a little
different for Frozen like I don't think
Aden Manzel would play Elsa in a
liveaction Frozen no they're like
teenagers yeah and they don't look like
their characters I guess this really
only works for
Dwayne yeah I don't know who I don't
there aren't really other like famous
voices in Moana is there Moana herself
she's about to be in Mean Girls musical
oh no way yeah who is she
playing I think one of the Mean Girls oh
I love that yeah but Mo Dwayne playing
Maui and also like Maui was inspired by
him a bit like it was very
sympatico yeah like his culture his
tattoos his tattoos right so I think
that's awesome I think Moana live action
will be
stunning yeah all that Oceanic panorama
yeah but who would play like the
liveaction Frozen that's a good question
honestly I feel like I keep using her
for everything rap Anna could totally be
Ona Taylor Joy or she sing that's a good
question I never stopped Z
Efron and you know we don't talk about
enough as a
culture how like he was in high school
musical CU they liked him so much even
though he couldn't really sing so like
in the movies Drew sely is singing and
Zach Efron is lipsyncing and then Zack
Efron kind of became like the guy for
musicals and he sang in the greatest
showman like why couldn't he sing in
High School Musical I think he stepped
his [__] up like yeah he took some
voice lessons I think he probably he was
in Hairspray yeah he probably has a
pleasant enough voice like he's not like
me where there's just no helping but he
could carry a tune and I think he had so
much potential to be a musical King like
he dances he acts he's down to clown
he's so down to clown that's an
important factor in the movie musical
actor no if you want to get in musicals
like you have to be the most unserious
person right so they were like if we
could just help this man unless you're
doing like lay Miz right if we could
help this man's voice he'll be
unstoppable and that's what they did
honestly it it to me it translates as
this is a person who was born to sing
like when I heard him on hairspray it's
the ladies choice choice choice I'm the
ladies like that to me is one of the
greatest musical performances of our
time I mean you're telling me that
person had to learn how to sing and he
wasn't just born singing yeah I think
Talent should needs to be honed without
love like hello but I also think what
makes him a great movie musical actor
it's not his his voice itself like isn't
amazing it's the whole package yeah even
in greatest showman like his I'm not
struck by his voice like I'm just struck
by the whole thing so it's just a small
part of the magic that is Zack Efron and
I always thought it was so cool how for
a very long time Zack was like the
hottest guy in Hollywood and he just
like loved to do musicals like it was so
sweet and cute and like and he was so
straight I was like this is so crazy I
never thought about it much but it's a
beautiful thing that I thought about it
all the time how like he was just like
singing and dancing queen but he was
also like this heart throb yeah I I
really never saw it that way but it's
beautiful yeah and I guess he was kind
of like a young Hugh Jackman and that's
why the greatest showman was so
beautiful cuz it really was the passing
of the Baton yeah but also young Hugh
Jackman
is gastone Luke Evans Luke Evans I'd
love that man I I could wa poetic I
could do a whole podcast on Luke Evans
but it's important to note I've
literally only seen him in Beauty and
the Beast like I'm sure he's worked on
other stuff I've never seen it but
that's sign of a of a great act like
when that one when someone's one role is
enough to sustain you we need to rewatch
Beauty and the Beast when we're on
vacation to the
I haven't seen it in probably a year and
it's oh and you know
what like now with this list we do have
to think about the children no cuz I
feel like I I've thought about this
we'll be watching when the children go
to bed oh okay but no but that's why
it's a great movie like Kayla loves
Beauty and the Beast yeah yeah yeah and
that's nice and stuff but like not to be
annoying like watching stuff with the
kids is annoying like they're like
jumping around and like we can't focus
oh wow no like it's we're going to be
watching this stuff when they go to bed
we're watching a golden Bachelor with
Kayla are we she would love it no she
would like be disruptive and I love her
but like if we're going to watch
something we have to watch it wow wow
well soon we can add Frozen 4 to our
lists of family friendly movies I didn't
even see Frozen 2 I'm not like a Fro I'm
not obsessed with Frozen it's good it's
really good no it was good it was good
you'll watch it you'll watch it and
you'll like it and I loved what they did
you know that first movie with like the
celebrity soundtrack Demi Lovato did Let
It Go rasco Vats was on there right no
they just uh they did like an offbrand
oh they did an Off Broadway cover yeah
they did this like you know every once
in a while I think it was David Foster
he put together an album of Disney
covers oh that's cool yeah it was good
and Rascal Flats did Let It Go with Lucy
hail it's like someone went into my
brain yeah so you're saying that wasn't
a Disney sanctioned work of art no it
was Disney sanction you can't sing their
songs without it wasn't like official it
wasn't like the official soundtrack of
Frozen it was just some people like riff
him that's too bad I love to riff and
rap yeah riff over here our fifth and
final story um is kind of crazy and it's
just funny the links will go too um to
not choose Jimmy Kimmel being Oscar host
as a story I support what is it whatever
it is I
love an escaped horse on a plane forces
the flight to turn back to
JFK the horse escaped the plane where
did he go so this is why details are
important cuz you think like how did a
horse end up on a plane without people
knowing but no well horses go on planes
it's not yeah it's not like that within
hours of taking off a plane was forced
to reroute and return to its departure
airport after a horse got loose in the
cargo hold o a Boeing 747 took off from
JFK on November 9th and once it reached
31,000 ft its crew requested a change in
flight plan as one of the 15 horses in
cargo had gotten loose the plane was
operated by air Atlanta Icelandic um the
the
horses were being transported there was
15 horses they were being transported to
across the pond like the idea of a horse
on a plane makes me want to cry no
literally I mean I didn't think much
about horses get how horses get around
these days but of course they do you
know they bring of course like when they
go to like the the big races well in
they usually stay on the same continent
I think yeah but still like if your
horse is in California you go to the
Kentucky Derby like you got to fly no
you drive I you drive you see those
horses on the highway all the time I see
horse on the I just imagine he's going
you know from one Farm to the next like
an hour away yeah I think if you're
going from California to Kentucky like
you drive because a horse on a plane is
an insane idea no it's insane but when I
think about horses crossing the Seas I
would have thought that they would go by
ship I would have well so I watched this
documentary once and I was sobbing it's
called share and the loneliest elephant
and it's all about this like this
elephant during Co that um was in like
one of these forlorn zoos in Pakistan
like it was just horrible and the zoo
lost its funding whatever and all the
animals whatever and they had nowhere to
put this elephant and he was like
decrepit and broken and sad and Sher got
involved and they they had to get this
elephant to like this
Refugee not no not what's the word
Sanctuary yes not Refugee sanctuary in
Cambodia how do you get from Pakistan to
Cambodia share was very helpful they got
a cargo plane and they like walked the
elephant onto the plane the elephant had
like broken legs he was in shackles it
was like one of these horrible zoos and
they had to train him for like weeks and
months before the plane because he was a
little violent because he was mistreated
for so many years so he had he gained
the love and Trust of this doctor and
this doctor was basically saying it's
his job to like help animals for who are
in captivity and then move on from them
and it's a very hard job because you get
so emotionally attached so he has
rurales like he won't emotionally attach
to these animals but this elephant like
stole his heart and this like Pakistani
veterinarian was crying and like I was
crying it was so sad it's such a good
documentary and then at the end like
because Shar is involved he obviously
it's a happy ending and he's like
thriving whatever and then they start
playing share like do you believe in
life after love let me tell you this
documentary changed my [__] life so I
did know that like in extreme
circumstances I mean they got an
elephant on a cargo plane well that's
crazy that a plane can take off with a
literal elephant yeah on the plane
that's amazing but I would okay so yes
technically you can fly a horse but I
would just think that I mean the journey
by sea is longer but like the air
pressure how does that affect horse I do
believe they like tranquilize them but
still air pressure no of course and also
like horses sleep standing up so like
for take off standing up and how is
there like a tall enough cargo hold I
don't I don't know and this is just one
thing like I don't want to know like
what if there was a horse on board with
Sully we always talk about the potential
dogs but what about a horse so that's
why it's crazy no but I don't think
there are horses on passenger planes
this was a cargo
Icelandic uh it was air Atlanta
Icelandic I believe that's like a cargo
airline yeah and so one horse got loose
they had to turn back around and got
loose like from cargo so like got out of
his stall
okay and they had to turn back around no
cuz if this was a passenger plane and
like my ass had to turn around because
some someone's [__] horse wasn't
clipped in like I would be so mad when I
hold on there's more details about how
the horse got loose but when I first
read this story like I thought like a
horse accidentally ended up on a plane
no like I thought a horse accidentally
they said he escaped to the plane I'm
like he jumped out M play according to
the chairman of
Ark um the company that handles all
animal export important in quarantine
operations at JFK we have to have him on
the toast honestly I just feel like like
I hope he runs a clean business like I
feel like I'm really getting upset like
so apparently this is going to upset you
turbulence no no turbulence struck and
the horse jumped and managed to get it
two front legs over the front barrier of
its holding stall and then he got jammed
so the horse was then suspended over the
barrier with its front legs on one side
and its hind leg still inside the stall
so upon Landing he was met with um a
Veterinary Care team and he needed
equipment to help get him out okay
that's not as sad as I thought it was
going to be like he was probably just
scared and uncomfortable for a few hours
yeah but he wasn't probably in any
pain uh I don't know then the plane took
off again they were going to Belgium
that was the original destination
shortly after the horse was attended to
this is just like one of the things you
never think about like how what makes
you know like people buy livestock like
it happens all the time farming is real
um this just one of the things I just
wish I never knew yeah and especially
with horses like I feel like there
there's all different kinds of horses
breeds you know got your English horse
I've heard um they've got nice horses in
Hungary it's like how did they get to
Hungary unless they were born there yeah
no I think they like right it's a
certain kind of horse yeah it's just sad
and we have horses here Wild
West we do wild west the West is wild
it's going to stay wild it will forever
be
wild and that's your daily horse upate
stay wild you should stay
wild so yesterday when I went to this
dinner at Green Barrel like I was seen
with a bunch of people I didn't know
they were just like asking what I do and
they were like well what do you talk
about I'm like we talk about how horses
are wild we talk about how horses get
from one continent to
another like honestly cuz I feel like a
million years ago like I would have said
like we're a pop culture show like we
are but we're so much more than that I
feel like saying we're a pop culture
show just kind of diminishes the work
that we do for Animals you know and and
other subjects yeah I feel like there's
a better word for what we do which is
like how would they
entertainment entertainment but also
just like
lifestyle yeah but that sounds fake I
know we have a lifestyle podcast oh so
you're unemployed yeah let me you know
what let me look at thes source.com
we need a new word it's more just
like Humanity
style of style of living love love I
have a style of living podcast what do
you
do Humanity I like that cuz we talk
about all things like sometimes we laugh
sometimes we cry sometime we joke you
know yeah I feel like I need to look at
what like college like made honestly you
know what we we we call it
comedy yeah I always say like it's we
talk about entertainment stuff but we're
in the comedy category so it's
funny yeah but like no we we're we're
comedy podcast right we are I mean we
literally are no I know but I mean like
I'm not talking categories I'm talking
you know if I were to explain it to
someone yeah but that's like weird
because it's like okay so you just do
like comedy every day like knock knock
jokes what do you talk about
comedy funny things you need like blank
with a comedy bent
what you need like subject with a comedy
bent entertainment like now we're just
we sound like we don't have jobs like
pop culture yeah world
news yeah but then they're going to
think we're talking about NATO
yeah hold on un serious world news
there's definitely like a category on
people.com that like Humanities honestly
human interest okay they have news
entertainment Royals
lifestyle
lifestyle I think we're a lifestyle
podcast society and
culture should we move categories we we
are society and culture but that's like
also not a real we we have like a
cultural podcast
culture culture okay that's pop culture
oh now me forgetting that the word
culture is in pop culture literally like
I said I'm not smart but we also
Society social issues
I mean but them are just like sh
shouting
words social what we do shouting words
that's it what do you do for a living I
shout words
shout you know you make me want to shout
all right that's our show gorgeous
tomorrow's episode is the final episode
of the week we uh are wearing our new
merch so on Monday don't forget 10: a.m.
eastern time our holiday merch is
launching you'll see photos and exact
items on our Instagram throughout today
tomorrow and the weekend so make sure to
follow us at the toen thank you so much
for listening to the toast Millennial
Morning Show where we deliver the past
life stories you need to know every
Monday through Friday and YouTube so if
you're watching us on YouTube please fre
to subscribe and give this video a
thumbs up we're also available as
podcast and podcast can be found Spotify
T public radio radi cast box all the
places podcast find us toview about a
beautiful starting and wickedly talented
we are hope you guys have an amazing day
and we'll see you tomorrow love you
bye